on reste dans l'alimentation avec cette
enquête du mensuel Que Choisir sur un
aliment très à la mode notre bon vieux
pain il en existe maintenant de toutes
sortes blanc complet au sègle gros petit
mais justement que recouvr exactement
ces catégories les compositions sont
très variables l'information souvent
insuffisante l'urend dit Marie labor à
la base c'est une pâte presque
anonyme seulement voilà avant cuisson on
y ajoute de la noix des lardons de
l'olive et parfois tout en même temps
autre exemple pour ces futurs petit pain
ce sera grain de sésame ou de pavau
certaines boulangeries se sont presque
spécialisé dans ce type de pain fantaisy
complet aussi céréales et cetera tenez
nos pains au pavau les voilà ici il y a
plus de 50 variétés différentes de pain
et c'est cela justement qui séduit les
clients le pain est bon et puis le le
sésame ajoute une petite touche bon pour
exotique mais enfin ça change beaucoup
quoi beaucoup de variétés comme ça dans
absolument absolument oui oui d'ord ça
forme le goût et puis ça fait voyager
déjà changement de décor dans cette
boulangerie on joue moins la carte
authentique et pourtant l'un des
produits Phard ici c'est la baguette
dite de tradition française pour la
faire de la farine de l'eau et du Levin
un pain à l'ancienne le seul dont la
fabrication soit réglementée mais pour
une bonne baguette de bons produits ne
suffisent pas il faut aussi le
savoir-faire la matière première qui est
la farine est vivante elle vit il y a
dedans des ferments et à boulanger de
les provoquer pour découvrir différents
goûts qui peuvent être soit lacti soit
acéti donc plus goût de yaourt ou plus
goût de vinaigre au final cette fameuse
baguette tient plutôt bien la route même
comparé à une tradition ancienne qui
serait en fait plutôt mythique que
réelle ce qui s'est passé en France
c'est que on a on été surtout bouleversé
par la deuxième guerre mondiale on a
mangé un pain caca grossier noir B après
on a découvert moyen de Fire du pain
très blanc hyper blanc gonflé à blan
très beau mais pas bon aujourd'hui pour
une baguette de tradition française il
vous faudra débourser entre 20 et 30
centimes d'euros supplémentaires en
principe le prix de la
qualité,7